Surf's Up and filmed in ultra slow
motion this footage was shot off the
west coast of Ireland by this man Andy
Anson the filmmaker has been here for
two weeks to capture images of surfers
tackling waves of the larger variety The
Geysers on the Gulf nom it's always
important for me to get sunny shots and
shots that are spontaneous are usually
the best ones where games plus surf
spray the best shots on visage kata
today ya mean is filming let's be frank
a documentary on the life of one of the
best surfers in the world Frank Solomon
this is the first time the filmmaker has
worked with the South African surfer
as that Goethe tube he's a cool guy lots
of fun and it's easy to work with him
he's a real pro and everything is really
well organized how does that what we do
see is wentals can you turn a little bit
a bit in that direction word of andean
sins talents has spread around in the
surfing scene where he is considered a
go-to filmmaker
at 27 he's constantly in demand as both
a director and cameraman Jansen has also
worked with wind surfing legend
extraordinaire Robbie Nash sided team I
really enjoy the energy and dynamism of
surfing especially being out in the
fresh air that's great the people are
fantastically upbeat and the yams and
speciality is one of the toughest in
filmmaking he often risks his life in
the course of a day's work towering
waves and winds up to gale force 10 our
routine he also has to make sure his
equipment is up for the job much of his
work also consists of waiting spective
auto from TY it's really only a fraction
of the day the wave comes in three hours
you have maybe two or three good waves
and you have to film them perfectly you
can't change batteries polish the lens
or anything else you have to be spot-on
in customs iron and the y Anson thinks
films consisting of nothing but action
are boring his films always tell little
stories like this portrait of the
British kite surfer Hannah whiteley who
spends several months a year in Cape
Town Deanna giddy oh and as I want to
present the energy that's in me too I do
that I show images or conveying whatever
has to do with water or mountains raw
power of beauty and people sure and i'd
mention
and y Anson grew up in a harbor town in
northern Germany but now lives in Berlin
his training at a publishing house led
to his first contacts to the world of
surfing soon he was hired for film
shoots and later commissioned to make
promotional videos kept our mouths I've
always felt I was about 8 quite young
there were quite a few feature films
shot in the town where I lived and I saw
all the big film sets the dolly special
cameras all the lighting and I thought
that's what I want to do someday
dulcimers design of tigers all done
Jansen made his first full-length film
in 2014 a documentary about Madagascar
he had visited the country on vacation
and felt impelled to make a film about
it he spent two months living on the
island while filming it I like ice cover
for me for me madagascar was wonderful
because of the lovely people beautiful
landscape and amazing animals I've
kafana T other and y Anson often finds
inspiration for his images when he's
with his friends he says his best ideas
come up during conversation one
Commission often leads to the next so he
works for months at a time he says he
has little time left for himself
I'm I no flights out of a safe here in
my free time I work on my own things for
example I build cameras or underwater
casings or I'm over the stove cooking or
I hang out with friends I don't do much
partying even though I live in Berlin
women in Berlin warned Allah despite the
stress making his living with films as
his dream come true he'll be shooting in
island for another two weeks and then
it's off to Hawaii fairs next project